there are some very interesting
developments in 2020 democratic polling
I know by now that merely reporting on
polling losses me subscribers and makes
a lot of people very angry but there are
new polls that are just too interesting
not to talk about now the highlights are
there's two sets of highlights okay I'm
just the messenger here I didn't do the
polls in two recent national polls
Elizabeth Warren has taken the lead
ahead of Joe Biden nationally okay in
one recent poll Andrew yang is in fourth
place polling 8 percent in that one
particular poll so let's discuss don't
kill the messenger I didn't do the polls
I'm just reporting on them so let's
start with the national polls there are
two recent national polls one from
Quinnipiac and the other from The
Economist Elizabeth Warren has taken the
lead nationally in both of these polls
with 27% support Bernie Sanders is at
16% in both of them Joe Biden at 25% in
one poll at 26% in the other so these
are effectively statistical ties with
Joe Biden then we get to this Andrew
yang poll the latest Emerson poll which
has Andrew yang at 8% nationally so the
immediate question is is Andrew yang
really polling at 8% nationally now I
find it very hard to imagine that that's
the case I know that the yang Kang US
will absolutely destroy me for saying
this but in every other poll Andrew yang
is at 2 to 3 percent if he gets another
couple of polls that say Andrew yang at
6
Andrew yang at 7 I will have to rethink
my analysis but I don't believe that
Andrew yang is actually polling 8
percent nationally I don't believe if
you hold if you held every primary today
I don't believe Andrew yang ends up with
8 percent of the votes in the Democratic
primary now what is most jarring here is
the Bernie decline Bernie Sanders was
polling anywhere from low to mid 20s
about a month ago and he now other than
the Emerson poll which also has yang at
8% which raises some questions just
about every recent poll has Bernie
between 14 and 19 percent now to be
clear I don't like this okay
Bernie's the most progressive
candidate followed by Elizabeth Warren I
wish Bernie Sanders was doing better but
if you look at the state numbers they
also aren't looking that great for
Bernie and it makes me think that
there's probably at least some truth to
the Bernie decline if you look at Iowa
the latest poll has Bernie well down in
third place with only 11% if you look at
New Hampshire which is the second
primary on the schedule Bernie is also
down in third place with 12% if you look
at Nevada the third primary bernie is
down in third place with 14% and then if
you go to South Carolina which is the
fourth primary before we get to a bunch
of them on the same day bernie is still
in second place but that's a month old
poll with relatively stale data when
Bernie was in second place in more of
these polls so I want Bernie to do well
but if Bernie can't win at least one of
those first four primaries I see a
difficult path for Bernie Sanders to the
nomination let me know what you think
and honestly guys at this point just
talk to me about what you think is going
on here don't smear me don't say I'm a
shill for this person or that person
these are not endorsements of any
particular candidate I've made it clear
I believe Bernie is the most progressive
candidate followed by Elizabeth Warren
I'm not gonna smear either of them I
would be delighted to see either of them
as presidents of the United States in
the sense that they both would be the
most progressive president in the United
States in the modern political era this
is what the data says and at a certain
point we're gonna have to just deal with
the data and stop the smears and stop
the ancillary stuff so I do want to hear
from you let me know what you think